[Musique]
en
bonsoir mes petits amis vous savez petit
louis et mirabel sont allés au cirque ça
d'après midi ils ont vu des tas de
choses amusantes des clowns des
acrobates et de grosses baie des singes
des girafes des tigres et même des lions
que de bruit mais qu'est ce qui se passe
dans cette maison qu'est-ce qui se passe
rose ours vient alors d envie de voir au
jeune couple
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que ça acision
émollient lot coucher moi j'ai les baies
l'avion afin d'en manger
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
ouah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est évident les gens auraient ils
n'ont jamais se battre nice ne va pas
être content du tout ça non allons au
lit et en vitesse il un garnement et ne
recommencez plus abou bakr sans rien
faire à moi je roule fort tout de molly
garnements faut tout ranger
le
[Musique]
que le travail coup garnements
vous voyez ils ont été très vilain ils
se sont battus et s'il recommence
nous ne reviendrons plus les voir bonne
nuit les petits enfants embrassez vos
parents allez vite vous coucher et à
demain bonne nuit
[Musique]
où
on